you come from above
like him
he will burn the world to find you
oh are they talking about Jesus
conqueror let's talk about Jesus
and Thor Ragnarok when we saw the gods
King was actually in one of the seats he
was dressed up as Jesus he was standing
in the corner on a cross
no one questioned it Rama Jesus this is
his baddest self I will take my revenge
on those who banished me and I will burn
them out of time yeah oh my gosh
is
he deserves it he deserves it right what
do they do what do they do just want to
burn people out of time for no reason
there was something I wonder if they
dated at some point I mean this
narcissist would date himself so like I
wonder if he's like you know what I hate
them because they broke my heart
for Zeus now myself what's going on here
well we know what the Mt Dynasty would
look like it'd be one big pile Oh yeah
thank you I would watch Jesus Jesus
I'm getting two of them you and I are
going together we're sneaking in from
snacks
jury duty I have jury duty
we want to thank nordvpn for sponsoring
the show today more on them in a bit
welcome back to New rockstars Ant-Man
and the watch Spotsylvania releases next
week and as we get closer and closer to
the date Marvel decides to release all
these new clips and featurettes that
give us very much less Clarity so today
we'll be diving into the mysterious King
the Conqueror and how he can actually
burn people out of time this is inside
Marvel new Rockstar's weekly Marvel
reaction show I'm Jessica Clemons here
today with Eric Boss at Mt what's going
on me and Eric got invited to a private
screening a little bit earlier this week
so we won't be spoiling a single thing
and we are just asking questions I'm
talking to the bourgeoisie over here
guys I don't know a thing about the
quantum Mania and they're over here it's
the secret knowledge okay the secret
dark old knowledge from from the
subatomic realm I didn't ask for the
crown
but you're wearing it thank you uh I
didn't ask for this but you guys first
first of first again be sure to check
out new rockstars merch.com where you
can always grab the latest greatest new
rockstars gear and our boys are wearing
it today yeah look at their sweet sweets
our merch Partners have recently changed
their names to nerd Ryan we're working
closely with them to develop more
exciting merch options right now you can
check out our newest line of the Ant-Man
and the washconds and Mania merch and if
you order now you can get the merch in
time for Ant-Man the WASP opening
weekend support the channel and check
out our great merch options over at new
rockstarsmerch.com or nerd Riot and also
if you see another person wearing the
shirt at the opening go slap chest with
them you know you know what I'm saying
the first question for our inside Marvel
today what does it mean to burn someone
exactly out of time what does that even
mean Kang mentions in the featurette I
will burn them out of time in the
trailer scenes with Kang yelling and
bursting blue energy beams from his
hands he could be burning people up in
those scenes we know from Whitney's
breakdown that Kang has the ability to
shoot electrical burst and fry people
could that be it or are we more looking
at like a pruning situation from Loki
season one thinking that we're dealing
with a roasting situation where he's
gonna burn them with words he's gonna be
like a ball but your shoes look like my
God knows me some ratchet ass sandals
[Music]
like Kaiba from Yu-Gi-Oh he pulls out a
microphone and immediately just starts
going at it right I just hate this
freaking Eight Mile but no I think that
we're dealing with a probably a printing
situation I would imagine what what do
you guys think I mean what do you guys
know I mean yeah I think it's I think
it's still we don't know we don't know
we know a lot about Quantum media and
we're being very careful about saying
anything to avoid spoilers as Jess said
but like I will burn them at a time it's
really just like some kind of imagery
that exists in getting to conquer his
head and I think it's specific it's not
just pruning it's my thing because you
know pruning pretty harmless pretty
harmless pretty painless I guess there
were some of those Minutemen in Loki
season one who are like ow
so maybe it hurts where am I going maybe
it hurts I mean Moby has screamed and
that guy you could I I held a lighter
under mobius's hand for like five
minutes and he didn't Flinch so I don't
know
um but no I think Kang is specifically
going to torture people when he says
burn them at a time he's gonna start
with his loved ones and start with their
pets and work his way up he's going to
go through his siblings the cousins he
doesn't really like but then go to his
loved one because I think this paint
this Kang has been painfully scarred not
just here but like in here and I think
what that means is they took rentslayer
from him and so he's gonna take their
loved ones from them and that's what he
means burn them at a time he's gonna
burn their line of succession
bloodline is taken by splitting them
apart from each of their lovers to make
them as lonely as they are and then
they're going to be begged to be killed
and that's what he means burn them out
of time that's what I would do
when you say well are you saying so
you're not saying it wouldn't be a
physical actual flame killing them
burning their flesh you're saying
metaphorically he's gonna like
you're gone out of time forever I think
I think it'll maybe it'll get to a flame
whatever you know the most just
punishment is for that particular Kang
uh oh empty I got a crazy pitch for you
what if to burn someone at a time is
what the coven was trying to do to
Agatha and that they were trying to burn
her out of time and that's what it looks
like and that's why it was a purple
Force I'm asking you about your your
color theory Mt the purple force that
overtook Agatha in that moment was that
Kang's doing was he preserving her from
being burnt at a time and then burnt
them at a time and then what happened to
that Covenant is what will look like to
all of Kang's targets ooh I really like
that idea of the coven wanting to burn
Agatha out of time because she's like
she read the dark hold and now she's a
threat so potentially multiple universes
as we learned from Multiverse abaddness
so like yeah like I this imagery of them
burning them out of time because it's
their Duty as witches I I like that a
lot
um but yeah no I think I think that
Agatha was glow purple in that moment
because she read the dark hold as a blue
witch so like it's like blue plus red
because the dark hole is red it's like
now she just absorbed Powers because she
has purple absorbing powers like Eliot
and like a bunch of people of the MCU
that use purple
um so yeah I I but I really like this
idea of using these energies to burn
someone out of time because like you're
just too much of a risk like you cannot
exist in the Multiverse this is what the
Illuminati would probably do
um if they got a hold of you so like
yeah I like this do you think the other
Kang variants have the same ability to
do the same thing so when he who remains
have what his version of burning people
out of time be the pruning situation do
we think it's to degrees different
variations of burning people alive it
could be pruning physically or just
metaphorically pulling them out of a
timeline that's a good question yeah
because I guess we don't really know I
would imagine that like uh Kings have
the ability to you know whatever a tva's
ability is is the Kang's ability to do
that I guess we don't really know yet if
each Kang has their own CPA or if the
TVA is kind of like
something that he remains created to
like hide himself uh and then it's kind
of a neutral zone
that you hide from his other variants
um but I think at least what the TDA can
do a cane could do no I I think that
Loki actually told us that like that's
exactly what he who remains did to win
the war because like he weaponized
eliaith by finding a life in the space
between realities and he was like all
right I'm gonna start I'm gonna build
these TVA weapons based off of a live
technology to literally prune people and
burn them out of time and so like maybe
I'm thinking that there's a similar line
of thought there because they're the
same under they're not the same person
but they're the same version of the same
person so maybe there's like all right
um maybe this is a king that lost the
first war is like you know what I know
of a life now I know that like um he
remains to use that against me so like
maybe I want to get a piece of that
alive pie and start burning people out
of time too as my revenge but I love
that I want that more than anything I
you would love I would I just like the
idea of him taking that weapon learning
from like his mistakes and being like
you know what up to the next World next
place and I'm gonna use what I learned
here and destroy it I would love that oh
my God Mt
take this somewhere the the idea of
burning someone out of time right so
Kang is kind of like uh he's like
weaving a tapestry he's got this rope
this braid of the Sacred timeline or at
least that was he who remains we assume
other kangs are might be involved in
that too but to burn someone out of it
like to prune someone it's just clip the
branch and then weave it back into the
but to burn it leaves a scar it's kind
of like when he's uh when he's what's it
called when you burn a wound to keep it
yeah it's Searchers I know what you're
talking about
[Music]
there is also another word that you were
correct on that's not cauterized but
it's kind of the opposite of suturing a
wound because you're not doing the
stitches that's what can't that's what
he remains would do is he would use
thread to do this but instead you're
burning it to leave a scar which means
you want to send a message you want that
timeline to still be scarred into like
send a message to anyone else who could
observe timelines don't [__] with me and
I think that's what he means to burn it
out of time he doesn't care about the
impact that it leaves on the timeline
like he doesn't care about the
Heartbreak it's kind of like what Thanos
did by snapping you know there's like
the other 50 percent of the survivors
are left behind uh it's kind of like
what the Avengers did by bringing
everyone back they don't think about the
impact and I think that's what it would
mean to burn someone out of time I like
that what do you think would be the the
leftover burnt ash what would be the
remind would it just be the husk of the
whatever he destroyed I think a pair of
smoking shoes
they'll be like wow it's either a really
good basketball player or someone just
died
oh my gosh you guys okay okay we'll get
back into inside Marvel but first we'd
like to take a moment to thank the
sponsors that help bring inside Marvel
to you have you ever had a situation
where you wanted to watch one of your
favorite movies or series only to
discover that it's not currently
streaming in your country one way to get
more content options in your life is to
check out nor VPN with nordvpn you can
change your virtual location with just
one click which makes it easier to find
streaming platforms at a lower price we
can even access platforms that aren't
available in the US which I know you
guys want to do you guys want the UK's
Netflix with one click you can choose
from over 5400 servers in over 60
countries personally I use nordvpn a lot
when doing research for the breakdown if
I need to look at a cinematic reference
I just need I need to have access to
tons of content that might not be
streaming in the US but thanks to
nordvpn I can complete my research and
get all those sweet sweet breakdowns you
crave Plus nordvpn's benefits and
features go Way Beyond improving your
streaming experience so you can also
access games and discounts only
available in other regions and block
malware written websites while you
explore securely we encourage you to try
nordvpn for yourself so grab your
exclusive nordvpn deal by going to
nordvpn.com Marvel to get huge discount
off your nordvpn plan plus four
additional months for free and let me
tell you everybody likes free you don't
got to steal it's completely risk-free
with nord's 30-day money-back guarantee
Eric uses nordvpn how do you totally do
actually so Kelly and I when we were on
our honeymoon recently we started
watching this series on one day when it
was raining we were just like stuck in
the hotel a little bit which is fine
that's how I prefer to spend my time and
when we got back to the us we weren't
able to watch the same show but I fired
up Nord and we were able to watch it and
we were able to finish the season it was
great nice so that's with nordvpn that's
nordvpn.com Marvel for an exclusive
discount plus four months for free
before hopping into the quantum realm to
take on King the Conqueror you're going
to want to get a good night's sleep and
trust me you absolutely will and here on
new rockstars we love our sleep time
with Helix and we have for many many
years Helix makes premium mattresses and
bedding that are customized to fit your
needs and conveniently shipped right to
your door which Helix mattress is right
for you if you don't know don't worry
about it Helix made a sleep quiz that
matches your unique body type and sleep
preferences to the perfect mattress for
you based on your different sleep
positions and firmness preferences they
have something for everyone's unique
taste and if you sleep with a partner
you can take the Sleep quiz together and
find something that's perfect compromise
for the both of you what other mattress
company does that I have my Helix and
I've loved it ever since I didn't even
have to carry it up the stairs I opened
it it it jumped out at me and I put it
in my bed and I sleep on it every night
and now I have no back pain or neck pain
ever again and I will keep this mattress
until I die the best part about all of
this is that Helix delivers a mattress
straight to your door with free shipping
in the US that's a big deal plus Helix
has a 100 night sleep trial so you get
more than three months to make sure that
you love it or you get a full refund
again what mattress company does that
Helix mattresses have a 10 year warranty
and they even offer financing options
and flexible payment plan so a great
night sleep is never too far away I love
my healing so I think you would too and
if you're looking for a new bed check
out Helix you can click the link below
or go to helixsleep.com inside marble to
get 20 off your Helix mattress plus two
free pillows and these pillows are
incredible that's Helix sleep.com inside
Marvel okay back to our thing the first
part of our featurette at the very
beginning
Torah says You Came From Above like him
is this King a god well I guess all
kings are kind of gods but is this king
from Earth and or uh who just developed
his own powers in science he who remains
mentioned a lot of different versions of
himself so How likely is that we can see
the versions from different timelines
that are actually from Earth do we think
they're from the same spot as the Langs
well based off of um the Mt or GI
watched Mt you always come from above so
what do you think oh yeah that's that's
specifically the only way I like to come
from
um is from above really
um
he comes out from the ceiling in a
wizard robe that's me uh that's my
that's my Kink and I'm just like the
worst part is that it it took me a
minute to think about it
I don't know what I'm saying and then
when I thought about it I said you know
what
you know what I should leave the time I
guess on this show I just throw a wrench
into it I'm becoming what I'm becoming
everything that I hate and I'm sorry I
love it
do you think that he doesn't even have
to come from Earth it's just like you
came from above like he did is there a
possibility that what what is above to
the quantum realm I think this is
interesting I think it tells us that the
quantum realm is a shared realm space
that connects to every different
universe and every different timeline we
have to assume that the king the
Conqueror who who is now in the quantum
realm and quantumania is from a
different timeline it's from a different
Universe than the uh than the infinity
Saga universe that we've been with
because I think we would have heard of
him we would have heard of uh I mean I I
think he may be in the shadows somewhere
in the universe I think there's like you
know my theory right now is that like uh
Kang Q E and G is currently who occupies
Avengers Tower and we just haven't crane
the camera up at it yet but uh yeah I
think um yeah I think it means it's a
shared space and that like what we're
seeing in the quantum realm are deposits
from just leftover scraps from every
different universe and that's why it's
just so [__] weird down there
I love it I love it I can't wait for
everyone to see what the quantum realm
looks like it looks so there's a lot in
these trailers but you won't yeah we've
seen a lot we see a lot but Jess would
you agree that we only see maybe 50 of
the full quantity I always say with most
Marvel movies especially like wakanda
forever you see a lot but then you
didn't really know what the plot was
right the kind that's the same place
that's what I feel for quantumania you
see a lot in the featurettes and things
you're not being spoiled because you
don't know what the plot is the plot is
not at all with the trailer Snippets
make it look like right which is so fun
that's the best part yeah but it really
is the best part hey when trailers spoil
things
um but no I I think that um when she
means above like there's like this
obviously there's a microverse which is
the Quantum realm there's a macroverse
which is like oh realm and I think of
the MCU
um like we're going to find out that
there are multiple just levels to like
the the cosmic scale and like um they're
in a in a um one of my favorite blue
Marvel stories uh blue Marvel and a sun
um have to stop the coming of this dude
called the the infinite and he comes
from a higher plane he's basically an
Ant-Man who was trying to come to the
the regular plane he's like oh because
he was like himself a uh a Micronaut a
microverse Explorer and so in the Marvel
Universe there are just multiple layers
of realities where people just get
things just get bigger and bigger and
bigger I think that's what the Ant-Man
movies are all about it's just like
everything's all perspective everything
on our our universe is a lot more bigger
than just our you know our planet like
our planets and our planet like there
are smaller people and there are much
bigger people and like the the universe
is just crazy
um and so yeah I I really hope that we
spend more time in the quantum realm of
future Marvel installations because like
I love the micronauts so much and I like
now that technically they don't have the
rights of the micronauts they have the
right to be Enigma Force now and so um I
really hope that we get an enigma Force
movie uh because I love Arcturus ran so
much and I want to seems I will I agree
with you I completely agree with you so
is there uh going on this possibility
that if he did come from Earth not to
take it back to there has there been and
maybe this is
a big bigger question than I expected
has there been a king
just a normal Man From Earth that's not
like Iron Lab Mr Griffin from uh the
Young Avengers run
um he's one he's a guy who owned King
Tower oh yeah oh okay because I was like
what if there's the possibility that
that's who they're talking about oh oh
oh he came from above
yeah uh I think in this context yeah
coming from above could mean just any of
the any of the aboves you know but
you're right it is a much bigger
question Jess like I I do think that
there is at least one Kang Incarnation
who has been in the infinity Saga that
we've seen so far I just think it's too
good it's too exciting of an opportunity
to to explore for Marvel not to do that
I feel like there's also
um a big chance that we see the king
very in Victor timely
um who
um he's like in in the Marvel Comics
like he's revealed to have been a
robotics expert I feel like there's a
chance that we could see Victor timely
go after Vision because like in one
division there was this like really
weird dude in the van with um
um homegirl from Two Broke Girls why
can't I remember anybody's name um
I'm just and like because like obviously
because a vision and all that stuff and
like we don't know we know sword wants
Vision back so I feel like we're gonna
see Victor time and be like hey guys I'm
secretly paying but I want to help you
find this robot for my own ends
um so I don't know like we could we
could see him mess around like that so
either Victor timely or um Mr Griffin I
can see being the normal Kings just
walking around her uh every time you say
okay first off I agree with you secondly
every time you say Mr Griffin I think
you're talking about Peter Griffin from
Family Guy
I'm like Peter freaking sweet oh my God
I want to go back to what boss said
about or and both of you how the quantum
realm could be a potential level on
level on level I know that they did get
rid of them uh they kind of absorb the
term macro verse yeah and getting rid of
the the
we'll pay the people that live down
there or whatever but is there a
possibility that if there are different
layers to the Mac the to the quantum
realm like complete like literal layers
like a cake
is there always just gonna be someone
above someone is there always is it
gonna be different civilizations that
don't know the other one exist or is it
like Rick and Morty how there's like oh
yeah we made this fluego box in a
Whatchamacallit crank and it's inside
inside
hmm I think this is a big question
because I'm just I'm like this is insane
I think every I think it's like if you
live in an apartment building you're
aware of your upstairs neighbors you
don't really know your downstairs
neighbors so I think you're always aware
of the layer above you because they're
always you know their Plumbing affects
your plumbing if they're you know so
it's always like an issue so uh I don't
know I don't think that metaphor works
that makes sense
it genuinely I read so much into these
things because of this job that it could
easily just be like yeah he's just a God
that came from the sky to these people
like gen Torres never from what it looks
like has never came out of the quantum
realm so it's like she's just like yeah
this guy showed up from this guy
basically like I think that that's
basically what's gonna be because like
as Hank Pym is going down to the quantum
realm like you can sort of see like the
different layers because like there's
the the tartar grade feels where like he
runs into that those big tartar grades
that I was about to eat his ship that's
its own plane of existence right there
like the tardigrades probably have no
idea what's going on on um in the
quantum room Quantum realm as he goes
deeper and deeper lower so like we're
seeing like different sandwiches of
reality where different beings live
um and so yeah I feel like once once
like Scott and um
um and
a big blanket on his name um Scott and
Janet and hope and and Hank come down to
the quantum Realms it's gonna be like
whoa you guys came from the sky we have
no idea what's up there because like
we're just chilling down here and now
like you you guys coming down here makes
us like believe that there is now life
above us so like now they're reality
shattered
um and so it's basically like uh
celestials visiting us it's like
celestials are like the next level of
humanity and so like Scott Lang and I
feel like with Scotland's mask like if
you go back to Ant-Man 2 when he's like
just big and like he comes out of the
water like that looks like a Celestial
like like I feel like Marvel is sort of
making that comparison slowly it's like
well celestials look weird to us because
like we cannot comprehend their their
larger purpose because they were from a
higher different place it's like the uh
the flat world uh short story that like
Carl Sagan mentioned when he talked
about how we can conceive fourth
dimensional beings and fourth
dimensional objects that humans only
exist in three dimensions but you know
the way that the uh the celestial
Airship appeared uh in and out was he
traveled through a black hole and that
is you know theoretically what a fourth
dimensional being would look like they
would just appear out of nowhere blip
into existence and then blip out of
existence so you're writing see maybe
celestials exist on like a higher fourth
dimensional tier of existence that we
can't conceive exactly because like if
we learn from eternals that they came
into the uh Universe through the Big
Bang so that's basically them coming
through from another plane of existence
because like this existence didn't exist
before they because they existed before
our existence it's so crazy I love I
love the MCU so much because it makes
you think about these this weirdness I
just don't want Scott Lang to be the
celestial of the quantum but I guess he
technically is like he works with Hank
Pym that's been
so one of my favorite moments in Marvel
Comics is when Hank Pym grows so big
that he actually beats eternity and
Eternity names him of the scientist
supreme or something like that because
he's like yo like you you're like
literally the best you reached me you
got so big that you reached me
um and so like I love seeing the
perspectives
the perspective
hey piss a dick like it's easily and
comes with the guy who like in his first
month goes right to the CEO's office and
it's like I'm actually really cool and I
was like oh great yeah I guess you can
now have project manager title and
people have been there for 12 years of
like this little piece of [__] just has
one drink
deal you're like he really does he
really does suck he made so many enemies
like all the enemies from the Ant-Man
movies are his fault uh he made Ultron
in the comics he made I mean look into
Hank Pam's much nicer Comics Hank Pym is
a real piece of [__] I think they had to
make him nicer because you wouldn't have
watched the first two movies if he was
him from the comics he was worse than
Iron Man and Iron Man was pretty bad
yeah but what if Hank pin was more
comics accurate it was more common what
if it was unhinged I was like yeah
that's the afib I know from the college
well geez yeah I I so where did he come
from he might have possibly been a
Celestial along with styling
um where'd he come from he dropped from
this guy I also like that idea of
something dropping from the sky and not
immediately killing it
um that if the people in the quantum
realm don't do that then good on them I
feel like normal earth like human beings
like cavemen would straight up be like
we gotta kill it we don't even wait for
it to fall from the sky we'll shoot that
balloon down as soon as we see him
oh God he said it but he said it I
didn't say anything impossible reference
he said that balloon's getting shot
that's it for this episode of inside
Marvel you guys are a reminder to
subscribe to the Deep dive the channel
Deep dive in ah this is boss who's a
little Channel little it's big it has so
many subscribers already yes thank you
guys look for subscribe to the Deep dive
doing okay for now as soon as they see
the content they're gonna be like what
did I sign up for no no no no no no
how dare he tell me the truth and let me
tell you he's gonna be telling he's
gonna be telling a lot of truths follow
me at Lulu underscore Clemons follow
Eric E A Vos and Mt at mastertonment on
Twitter subscribe to inside Marvel
wherever you get your podcast guys go
watch Ant-Man and the watch quantumania
go get our merch and then go wear it to
the premiere maybe I'll be there if I'm
there I'm gonna slap it I don't sign
things I only slap things thanks for
watching bye bye can you sign my popcorn
sure slap
[Music]